[موسيقى]
الاخبار اهلا بكم اعتقل مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه المشتبهه فيها بتسريب وثائق
البانتاجون وهو جاك تشيره احد افراد الحرس
الوطني الجوي في
وقالت وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه انه
اختصاصي بتقنيه المعلومات في استخبارات
الحرس الوطني
مثل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
امام الادعاء العام في نيويورك على خلفيه
دعوى مدنيه حركتها المدعيه العامه ووجهت
الى تشامبو وشركته وثلاثه من ابنائه تهم
تضخيم الثروه بوهيه الاستفاده من قروض
ووصف القضيه برمتها لانها سخيفه وتدخل
بالانتخابات
قال المتحدث باسم الوثائق التي سربت حساسه
وانما حدث جريمه متعمده ورفض المتحدث
مناقشه تفاصيل الوثائق المسربه بسبب
حساسيتها وتاثيرها على الامن القومي
والحلفاء والشركاء حسب تعبيره واوضح ان
العمل متواصل مع الوكالات الفيدراليه
لمعرفه حجم الضرر الذي احدثه
الجيش السوداني الدعم السريع بحشد قواته
داخل العاصمه وبعض المدن وحذر من منعطف
خطير تمر به البلاد وقال مصدر في الجيش
للجزيره ان قوات الدعم السريع ادخلتنا
قلات جنديلا العاصمه نقلت من شمال دارفور
قال اعلام قوات الدعم السريع عند نائب
رئيس مجلس السياده محمد حمدان حميدسي عقد
اجتماعا مشتركا عبر الهاتف مع المبعوثين
الامريكي والبريطاني والنرويجي بايشان
التطورات التي يشهدها السودان وشهود
استكمال العمليه السياسيه واوضح اعلام
الدعم السريع عن لحم اكد حرصه على تعزيز
الاستقرار ودعم مسيره التحول الديمقراطي
بالبلاد
وعرب المبعوثون والممثلون الخاسرون من
فرنسا والمانيا والنرويج وبريطانيا
والولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
اعربوا عن قلقهم البالغه تصعيد بين القوات
السودانيه وقوه الدعم السريعه ودع
المبعوثون القاده العسكريين والمدنيين
لاتخاذ خطوات فعاله لخفض التصعيد
في العراق اعلن زعيم التيار الصدريه مقتدى
الصدر تجميد التيار لمده عام على الاقل
لمحاربه من سماهم المفسدين داخل التيار
وقال الصدر في تغريده قبل ان يغلق حسابه
ان التجميد يستثني اقامه صلاه الجمعه
الموحده وهيئه التراث الخاصه بالطياره
اندلعت مواجهات في العاصمه الفرنسيه بين
الشرطه ومتظاهرين رافضين لقانون التقاعد
الجديد وقد خرج متظاهرون في عدد من المدن
سلبيه لدعوه النقابات العماليه احتجاجا
على القانون
الى اللقاء